I am Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report lockdown baby prison planet
global lockdown a lot of things are
being revealed as the tide of
neoliberalism goes out yes one can
assume until we say otherwise that we
realize we are under lockdown as is most
of the rest of the world this is the
Cova dean pandemic on going around the
world but on top of that we have a
money-printing pandemic we have a u.s.
Fiat dollar global system pandemic that
we've been discussing for the past ten
years here on Kaiser report and one of
the people most responsible for the
imbalances that we see in the world that
the the global trade imbalances the
global neoliberal imbalances caused by
all of this insanity of sending our
manufacturing overseas for example is
Larry Summers he was a Treasury
secretary under Bill Clinton from 1999
to 2001 so he oversaw a glass-steagall
removal he oversaw WTO except in China
into the World Trade Organization
he saw all those sort of things that
dismantled the Commodity Futures
Modernization Act
he saw the stuff that created the
destabilization that we see going on so
it was quite ironic or indeed quite
repulsive to see him tweet this Mack's
thoughts at the end of a long week why
can't the greatest economy in the
history of the world produce Schwab's
facemasks and ventilators inadequate
supply Larry Summers is a key figure in
America's downfall the problems of the
kovat 19 virus today and the problems in
the markets around the world have a
direct antecedent to Larry Summers and
that cadre of elites Harvard elites and
Wall Street elites who decided to
eviscerate the American economy carve
out everything and leave a rotting
corpse in their awake and now he's
frantically trying to deflect and assign
blame and point fingers and he needs to
look in the mirror
Larry Summers is a heinous repulsive
character in American history who is
goes down in history as somebody who is
Benedict Arnold almost quality there's a
saying that goes He Who smelt it dealt
it
well here's the guy who smells this
situation perhaps he's the one that
dealt this rotten smelly situation now
think about it in the United States as
we covered many times that the United
States is a hospital masquerading as a
country we have 18% of our GDP is
devoted to the health care system and
one of the arguments that many in the
think tanks and Beltway elite and Wall
Street elite why they argue that we need
to spend 18% is that we have where
innovators where like we have the best
health care system in the world so how
is that health care system unable to
produce basic personal protection
equipment that all hospitals need in
fact we saw a Columbia Presbyterian one
of the top hospitals in the world in New
York City plead online for any donations
they gave the address to send any of
your masks and especially a 9-5 mask to
them because they're about to run out so
how is that situation how does that
emerge when 18% of our GDP goes to
health care of course I think it was
Dick Cheney who said that Russia is a
gas station masquerading as a country
well are they ever gonna run out of
gasoline are they going to run out of
oil anytime soon no that would be the
equivalent so here we spend 18 percent
on our GDP and yet we can't provide any
health care we don't have ventilators we
don't have simple masks the explanation
is somewhat simple and Larry Summers
again plays into it and under his
treasury head during the Clinton years
is that sick people are predictable
income streams just like prisoners are
predictable income stream and whenever
you have a predictable income stream
like sick and dying people you can use
that to collateralize the bond market
and so we have the 40-year bull market
and bonds that just recently came to an
end but that's based on people on Wall
Street like Larry Summers and others
to collateralize that predictable income
stream to create a Mount Everest of debt
and to play games in the bond market to
create that Ron TA income that recurring
source of income how they to become
billionaires by capitalizing on sick and
dying people that's how the hospital
system became so huge in America is
because it's predictable people are will
predictably die and a good society
doesn't turn that into a profit Center
for the worst elements in society a good
society would downplay that and but
that's not America well another element
that is discussed widely online is of
course our hospitals are massive profit
centers owned by private equity and it
makes no economic sense you do not earn
any profit by having spare ventilators
in your basement they cost about thirty
five thousand dollars each and it makes
no sense to spend the money on that when
thirty five thousand dollars could go
towards stock buybacks or to executive
compensation so that's one of the things
but in terms of this kovat 19 I want to
discuss the fact that the CDC released
numbers about the mortality rate per age
group in America and pretty much under
44 it's a very low mortality rate
relative to the rest of the population
over 45 I mean it's not it's worse than
the flu but it's still low compared to
those over 45 so I want to point out
that the same thing the Cova 19 is also
hitting the currency of the US dollar
which is 49 many people are saying that
this is genuinely the moment kovat 19 is
killing has killed has put on life
support in the ICU there are no
ventilators left and people are looking
for some sort of ventilator or survival
mechanism for the US dollar but it went
from 1971 to 2020 that was the death of
the dollar and we could have flattened
the curve over the past few decades we
could have avoided this situation but we
we let it go out there and mingle and
and not do the social distancing
equivalent for a currency I've said this
before and I'll just briefly restate
this but this concept of Gaia which is
Mother Earth you can look it up online
Gaia GA I
is one of extreme and ultimate karmic
justice the dollar violated the rules of
Gaia by by putting money into the
pockets of the cancer that is a Larry
Summers and his friends and it also
created the imbalances in a country like
China where the the the the rush to grow
men obliterating all safety precautions
and so now we have a reversion to the
mean the stock market I could imagine
trading it eight thousand again on the
Dow and that would be an appropriate
level given the true underlying economic
factors the bond market interest rate
should be four and five percent in the
in the 30-day interest rate okay that
would mean bonds will be down fifty
sixty seventy percent but that's that's
the rate that's returned to a normal
valuation and that's what we need right
now speaking of bonds I actually have an
amazing chart for you and it's comparing
the situation in the financial markets
in particular in the monetary policy
markets is that this is the Cova
nineteen killing off the Fiat system and
the bond market as we've always warned
it's been like in a bull market for the
past forty fifty years that this is the
biggest market of all so when this goes
when this erupts and most people have
known only calm and bull market and
positive times when this erupts this is
the end essentially at the system this
is what a bond crash looks like value of
global bonds has plunged by five
trillion dollars to fifty five point
five trillion in the past two weeks
equal to the GDP of Japan investors fear
a tsunami of new debt as governments
around the world prepared to release
massive fiscal stimulus plans right the
the bond bull market the the bubble the
biggest bubble in the world economy and
all was not Bitcoin it certainly wasn't
gold it was the bond market the
sovereign bond market and when these
countries started the issue negative
interest rates sovereign debt that was
your big sign in the sky like a huge
Batman signal in the sky like this is
about to crash this is about to crash
the bond market of course we'll go
reversion to the mean it'll restore
it'll go back to its long term trend of
five six percent on a interim out of
ten-year bond sovereign top bond that
means a fifty to sixty percent markdown
in the bond market which means pretty
much every S&P corporation now it's
gonna have to declare bankruptcy give or
take a few
they're gonna need massive bailouts
massive restructuring massive layoffs
but this is the price to pay for for
blowing this enormous bubble this is a
bubble popping started with Clinton in a
huge way in Larry Summers and it's it's
funny that Larry's trying to point the
finger and when he was the architects of
this enormous bond bubble and Robert
Rubin and Alan Greenspan and Ben
Bernanke and Janet Yellen who said she
doesn't expect another financial crisis
in her lifetime and these are the happy
talked propagandist for the bond dealers
like Goldman Sachs and Citibank on the
others who have put this false sense of
security as if interest rates could go
forever negative that that's to say that
we would go backwards in time forever
because but the bottom line is that now
time has value as it should the yield
curve will get normal but not after
we'll see which countries can survive
the bond crash foreign countries it's
particularly in Asia who have been the
victim of America's bond bubble are
resilient and they're already coming out
of the Kovach crisis because they built
up resiliency the US has no resiliency
Goldman Sachs is expecting the economy
in the United States to decline by 24%
in the second quarter whether or not you
know we'll see civil disorder because of
that I know in our in terms of our just
in time a neoliberal sort of economy
there are I noticed supply chain issues
in our local area where supermarkets
still five six days later have no supply
so I don't know what people who haven't
stocked up or who don't have any
supplies at home a reasonable amount or
who have you know live paycheck to
paycheck I don't know what they're doing
and I
in fact Larry Summers did tweet that
right after his comment about why don't
we have any swabs he said why is
everybody buying guns he said he said it
says it suggests that people think
there's a civil disorder coming well
probably because they've been to the
supermarket a few times and see no food
well I want to point out that when you
mentions Asia why they're over it that's
because they have supplies they have
masks they don't have to shut down their
economy South Korea Taiwan Singapore
haven't had to shut down their economy
like we are having to do because they
have masks for everybody to wear and
that's really important not so much for
catching it but for spreading it so if
anybody who's asymptomatic or slightly
sick or anything like that and walking
around you're gonna get it from them
from just their breath if you're within
six feet of them but they all get to
wear masks and thus keep their economy
going we don't have masks for our
doctors let alone for our citizens so
again this is an issue that we've
decided to take this Multi multi
trillion dollars of hit a twenty four
percent decline in the economy and mass
unrest because we don't believe in that
socialist or communist or sort of
planning having five-year plans having
one-month plans is considered socialist
right Asia is resilient probably because
Larry Summers back in nineteen ninety
nine suggested to put off ship all the
jobs from American Asian Larry naughty
boy all right we're gonna take a break
when we come back much more coming your
way
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser are you know the great thing
about Twitter is you find people that
you start following and you find a
wealth of knowledge and information
let me introduce Dan tap Bureau I follow
him on Twitter he is a macro investor
for 25 years he's got lots of
interesting stuff to say about the US
dollar of gold and Bitcoin welcome Dan
all right thank you for having me all
right my pleasure now my first question
here is the Fed began the week with
announcing yet more new programs to help
markets including open-ended asset
purchases dan can the Fed fight kovat 19
with an exponential growth in its
balance sheet Dan yeah I mean I think
they need to there need to be offsets
the policy of shutting everyone in as
you know is going to lead to some
dramatic unemployment and contraction in
GDP and q - that's probably greater than
we've ever seen I mean it will be
greater Bullard last night the same st.
Louis Fed governor said he thinks it's
30 percent unemployment and 50 percent
drop in GDP I think that's a bit extreme
and Goldman and Morgan Stanley have come
out recently with sort of less extreme
but you know the there needs to be
extreme policy to lean against that kind
of contraction and we've also seen a
contraction liquidity in the markets
people don't realize this but quite a
few of the corporate credit markets
Muniz those markets have been frozen in
some cases I don't say no-bid but you
know virtually no bid for certain
securities and so that tells you that
the Fed really isn't doing their job
we've had an exogenous non-economic
shock and and really this is what
central banks have were invented for it
to lean against these type of things so
I think they've been very slow to the
punch and I'm glad finally this morning
that they have come out with such a
policy I'll say one more thing I think
that
you know we'll know this policy is
working not because the stock market
stabilizes which hopefully it will based
on this plus the fiscal policy but
because the dollar should start to
weaken if the dollar does not weaken
even with all this policy it tells you
that liquidity is not yet plentiful
enough and so that's sort of the measure
and as the dollar weakens and there's a
sign that there's more dollars in the
world because we're dealing with the
dollar shortage you'll start to get a
very strong move in gold as well alright
I'll focus on one thing that you
mentioned there he said that the Fed he
said this is what they're designed to do
to come in during an emergency situation
like this and be active my question is
this Dan looking at the history of the
Fed starting with Alan Greenspan and the
so-called Greenspan put and then the
Bernanke put and then the Janet Yellen
put and now that Jay Powell put it seems
like the Fed has not really been doing
what it's supposed to be doing and that
is taking away the punchbowl when things
get too frothy it seems like they've
actually been exacerbating this problem
for several decades and now here we are
in 2020 with the worst crisis in oh you
know depending on how you look at at 50
60 100 years and they they have no real
ammunition left dan dan what do you what
do you think
I think unlimited is plenty of
ammunition and I think if you know if
they were overly easy we would have seen
that as I said in the dollar the dollar
has been super strong against all
currencies and that tells you that
policy in fact in fact has been tighter
than should have been and I think in in
terms of taking away the punch bowl they
tried to do that in 2018 it led in
December to a complete wipeout again
largely because the underlying pressures
in the world economy are still
deflationary and there are a lot of
reasons for that and you can talk about
that for hours and hours so I don't
think the Fed has been
I think they tried to take away that
punch ball they never hit their
inflation target and late eighteen they
had to reverse course and then build up
the balance sheet again in in early
nineteen and that you know I so that
they pulled back from too tight of
policy and I think if they didn't pull
back far enough and then again in q4
last year they had to start expanding
the balance sheet again so I would argue
that the Fed policy has been too tight
for the last year and a half and one of
the things that also makes me think that
is that even when they brought rates
down to zero recently the real rate
skyrocketed
we went from minus 80 basis points on
the five-year real rate to plus 50 basis
points because inflation expectations
have completely collapsed and so what
we've seen so far is that even though
the Fed rate is at zero the Fed Funds
rate the real rate is much more positive
than it should be then that it should be
and so I think by going to unlimited
purchases they have a chance perhaps to
bring down those market rates to at
least be in line with the drop in
inflation expectations the second part
of this is don't forget oil is down 70
percent from earlier this year it is a
massive deflationary shock that we're
suffering there on top of the 25
trillion dollars in wealth that's been
lost in in the markets so I'm not in
agreement with you I think the Fed needs
to do more easing they've been too slow
and they've been focused on minutiae
little changes in the CPI a tenth here a
tenth there that's what they were
worried about in 1718 completely
misplaced inflation was never a problem
and now we have collapsing inflation
expectations and they need to reverse
those as does the government with a very
strong fiscal package here all right
let's talk about this GDP number for the
second quarter
the best-case scenario seems to be a 24%
drop which is would be the biggest drop
ever in the US and the worst case of
course considerably more how does that
impact gold and Bitcoin now
interestingly enough you're a macro guy
and you have been talking about Bitcoin
very constructively and you have a lot
of great insights into Bitcoin so I
think a lot of folks who are in the gold
camp are not necessarily in the Bitcoin
camp but you seem to equate the two
so how would how are those two assets
going to respond to what's happening
over the next two and three or four
quarters damn this contraction in GDP is
so large you know III don't think
authorities know how to respond to it I
think we're doing the best that we can
I think it's massively bullish gold it
might be the most bullish gold event
maybe since the since the Nixon Deep egg
to be honest and I think it's massively
bullish for Bitcoin as well
and you know the the the the part of the
reasons Bitcoin was invented was you
know out of the Oh a crisis and really
out of fear of extreme debasement of
fiat you know that gets talked about a
lot in in the Bitcoin space we need to
have the dollar go down and you know I
think policy will not be successful and
I don't think we'll be able to lean
against this contraction and it if it
doesn't go down so you know gold you
know gold is at 1560 right now and
that's with the dollar at its highs so
if policy is strong enough on both
fiscal and monetary to offset this
contraction you could have a 10 15 20
percent drop in the dollar that is
normal that isn't necessarily a reason
to panic you know yes there's some
debasement of fiat perhaps the dollar
drop will get the Europeans and the
Chinese off there actually help out this
process and do some real stimulus you
know if you look at European banking
stocks they're still down 90 percent
from the Oh 7 hi they're down 50% in the
last five six weeks you know the
Europeans are woefully have been
woefully inept and certainly not speedy
the Chinese still have interest rates
that you know bond rates at 3% they
should be down at one so a dollar drop
of significance would sort of force them
to act as well which would be a positive
thing yeah so you you you could be
looking at you know I don't know if the
dollar rallies five to ten percent first
or you know and that gets the
authorities to realize they haven't done
enough but I'm hoping that the bazooka
that we've seen here unlimited QE from
the Fed this big fiscal package I think
this should give the currency guys
enough of a of a sense and and there
should be a lot more liquidity out there
a lot more dollars out there and you
know without even considering all the
other things that are very positive for
gold you know we could be looking at a
15 10 15 20 percent dollar drop what if
things returned to a more healthy
situation
and I think that's that'll that'll bode
well for Bitcoin as well
look Bitcoin as I've said is ohm is its
own thing I think one of the things that
Bitcoin is this digital gold
I think it's many many other things is
well as Raul
you know ropal called it a call on the
future I think it's definitely that you
know it is I think of in the future I
think it will be the value protocol for
the for the internet for all
transactions of value if you look at the
safty nam who's you you know book he you
know he thinks it'll be the you know
collateral layer all of that stuff puts
a value on Bitcoin that's trillions of
dollars Italy we have enough time you
get into all that and I've talked about
that in other places
but all of this systemic or the systemic
breakage that were witnessing right now
this is why bitcoin was invented so I
don't know what could be more bullish
for Bitcoin what about the bond mark you
know the government bond market the bond
markets been in basically a 40-year bull
market and a lot of people have called
the top of the bond market for the last
ten or fifteen years and been wrong but
is have we finally hit the top in the
bond market and are we into now a
secular bear market for the bond market
and that would mean creeping interest
rates going higher now in a secular
basis down I think you don't really need
to call a top in the bond market I think
it's a very fancy call and I say that
because we really need lower rates for
an extended period here to offset this
massive contraction the Fed has just
told us that they're going to be doing
unlimited QE buying Treasuries and
probably mortgages and corporates as I
said I think it's a very it's a very
fancy call that you don't really need to
to make the risk/reward of making that
bed isn't at this moment today not great
it may be the top but I I don't really I
think there are plenty of other bets out
there investments for investors to make
that are a lot easier
well well well said dan you don't want
to end up in the pile of wrong bond
callers the Widowmaker as it has been
for the last 20 years well played sir
anyway thanks for being on the Kaiser
report
my pleasure all right that's gonna do it
for this edition of the Kaiser report
with me Max Keiser and Stacy Herbert I'd
like to thank our guest dan shapiro
follow on twitter it's great great to
follow johanna catch us on twitter
it's Kaiser report until next time bye
y'all
[Music]